сегодня мы поговорим о том как добиться
реально крутых результатов в бизнесе
инвестициях и жизни и кстати концепция
которой я сегодня с вами поделюсь
помогает достигать неимоверных высот и в
политике и в общественной жизни тоже это
второе видео продолжающееся
закономерно везёт и весь мир хочет чтобы
ты добивался целей так что оставайтесь
со мной будет
[музыка]
интересно вы никогда не добьётесь
действительно крутых результатов Если вы
не будете знать о том что такое
суперпозиция и как её правильно
выстраивать все люди которые добились
каких-либо крутых результатов они
интуитивно или неосознанно использовали
или используют инструменты супер
проблема Однако в том что они даже не
осознают этого А когда человек не
осознаёт причины своего успеха он не
может его повторить Именно поэтому успех
каждого крутого человека уникален Потому
что его невозможно повторить однако я
уже много лет занимаюсь тем чтобы
выявить и использовать законы и
закономерности достижения действительно
крутых результатов как в жизни так и в
бизнесе и
инвестициях это сво знание я объединил в
концепцию
суперпозиции это видео для тех кто уже
добился определённых успехов в бизнесе и
жизни но хочет большего поняв концепцию
суперпозиции вы поймёте что всё что вы
до этого делали это Суета сует это
настолько неэффективно насколько для вас
будет казаться неэффективными все
действия Муравья помещённого в
стеклянную
банку Если вы хотите достичь больших
реально больших результатов не убивая и
не жертвуя другими сферами жизни то
досмотрите это видео до конца это будет
самым главным и самым сильным скачком в
вашем понимании эффективности
подписывайтесь на мой канал ставьте
колокольчик активно комментируйте и
Поделитесь этим видео с людьми которых
вы считаете амбициозны поверьте они
будут вам очень
благодарны большинство людей связывают
большие достижения с трудом сши
связями Ну или везением так вот я знаю
очень много
людей Ну к которым я отношу и себя тоже
которые добились всех своих
достижений абсолютно не убивая на работе
и не жертвуя другими аспектами жизни так
что труд там и большие достижения я
считаю не имеют прямую корреляцию я об
этом уже много раз говорил в различных
видео так вот когда е говорят второе
когда
Том большие ресурсы Ну оправдывают
чей-то успех так вот это обоснование
тоже не выдерживает никакой критики
Потому что есть множество примеров когда
люди добивались действительно больших
результатов начиная с нуля и потом для
того для того чтобы у человека появились
эти ресурсы Ему же Ну он должен же был
их откуда-то взять сначала поэтому
второй аргумент Я считаю он тоже
несостоятельный третий аргумент - это
что решают связи там и так далее
знакомства от часть это правдивый
аргумент но связи тоже нужно сначала
наработать я здесь не говорю про
родственные связи или связи которые у
человека появились благодаря его там
рождению или там женитьбе на дочери
богатого и влиятельного человека Ну и
четвёртый аргумент что большие
достижения возможны только благодаря
везению Я бы назвал этот аргумент
наиболее приближенным к истине но всё же
это недостаточно
потому что одного везения тоже мало
например вам может повести там и у вас
подскочит цены или продаже вашего
продукта так вот Если у вас нету
инструмента масштабирования вашей удачи
или вашего везения то вы получите
минимальный эффект от повышения цены на
ваш продукт то есть само везение оно
отвечает только за стечения
благоприятных обстоятельств А вот
инструменты масштабирования вашего
везения отвечают за то сколько благ вы
извлечения Ну например в случае с ценой
на ваш продукт ваша прибыль будет
зависеть не только от повышения цены а
она будет зависеть больше от того
сколько товара Вы продадите по этой
высокой цене Если вы проанализируете
достижения всех крутых людей у всех у
них были какие-то поворотные моменты в
жизни когда их волной буквально выносила
наверх большинство миллиардеров стали
таковыми Бря не только своему труду а
больше благодаря везению и тому что у
них были инструменты масштабирования
своей удачи есть очень много людей более
трудолюбивых чем они есть люди не менее
удачливые чем они но однако же
миллиардерами стали именно Те кому
повезло и у них под рукой были
инструменты масштабирования своей удачи
я сам знаю очень много трудолюбивых
людей но я также знаю очень много людей
но однако они не добились значительных
успехов везение - это то что влияет на
взлёт любого человека будь то бизнесмен
инвестор политик или общественный
деятель А вот инструменты
масштабирования везения - это то что
позволяет извлекать из этого максимум
если взять например соотношение того в
какой пропорции Что влияет на конечный
успех или результат то я бы раскидал
примерно Вот в такой пропорции труд и
усердие это процентов 20 везение
наверное процентов 50 ну и инструменты
масштабирования - это процентов 30
везение определяет то оправдаются ли
взятый вами риск сложатся ли
обстоятельства в вашу пользу Будет ли
время играть на вас Ну и так далее То
есть везение - это основа для вашего
взлёта это как река с бурным течением
или можно даже сказать это такой мощный
восходящий поток воздуха который выносит
вас на вершину успеха а вот инструменты
масштабирования везения - это то что
определяет насколько высоко вы взлети и
то насколько сильно вы воспользуетесь
этим везением Давайте разберёмся с
определением того что такое везение
везение - это благоприятное стечение
временных и пространственных
обстоятельств вы Спросите А при чём
здесь суперпозиция Ведь именно с него Мы
начинали сегодняшний разговор так вот я
вам объясню суперпозиция - Это самый э
способ достижения закономерного везения
И извлечения максимального эффекта из
него А что такое закономерное везение и
как им воспользоваться я расскажу вам об
этом в следующем видео поэтому не
пропустите его А сейчас мы продолжим
дальше Оставайтесь со мной Пока
подпишитесь на мой канал поставьте
колокольчик и Поделитесь этим видео с
людьми которых вы считаете
амбициозны поверьте они будут вам очень
благодарны
[музыка]
Давайте на примере шахмат объясню как
работает
суперпозиция все люди считают что для
того чтобы круто играть в шахматы нужно
просчитывать как можно больше ходов
вперёд также кстати поступают и многие
бизнесмены пытаясь предугадать и
предусмотреть всё в жизни но это очень
далеко от истины на самом деле для того
чтобы круто играть в шахматы нужно
выстраивать супер позицию
а как это делается на шахматной доске 64
поля у меня и у противника по 16 фигур у
каждой фигуры есть свой Огневой
потенциал или можно сказать своя сила
так вот моя задача заключается не в том
чтобы просчитывать ходы противника моя
задача заключается в том чтобы
выстраивать Свои фигуры таким образом
чтобы каждая моя фигура била
максимальное количество полей
и благодаря этому каждая моя фигура
атакует фигуры противника и каждая моя
фигура защищает своих и у меня заметьте
при этом нет цели сесть или уничтожить
фигуры противника У меня также нету цели
его даже выиграть всё что я преследую
это я
выстраивают каждый ход противника
приводит к его поражению это есть
суперпозиция в шахматах
не полностью раскрывает потенциал и
смысл суперпозиции правда такого Термина
в шахматах вообще не существует это я
просто иллюстрируют то как работает
суперпозиция в шахматах Давайте возьмём
другой Пример например из сферы
инвестиций вместо попыток точно
спрогнозировать курс каждой акции или
актива гораздо эффективнее сформировать
диверсифицированный портфель активов в
котором любая рыночная волатильность
перекрывается другими инструментами и
более того любая волатильность только
укрепляет ваш портфель Ключевое заметьте
здесь не классическая диверсификация а
именно такая диверсификация которая не
позволяет вашему портфелю проседать но в
то же время ловить любые рыночные
колебания в вашу пользу таким образом
каждая ваша инвестиция как бы прикрывает
риски другой и даже неожиданные рыночные
события работают в вашу пользу Если вы
не будете создавать суперпозиции в
инвестициях то все ваши инвестиции будут
как короткое дело голову закроешь ноги
откроются ноги закроешь другая часть
тела вылезет наружу суперпозиция в
инвестициях - это когда ваш портфель
использует любые тренды и колебания в
вашу пользу с максимальным эффектом
давайте рассмотрим Как можно выстроить
суперпозиции в жизни для того чтобы
понять как выстроить супер позицию в
жизни вам нужно сначала ответить себе на
три базовых вопроса
первый каков этот мир или Какова эта
реальность Что за игра в которую вы
играете Каковы правила этой игры или
жизни вы играете в свою игру или вы
играете по чужим правилам второй кто я в
чём моя сила И в чём Мои слабости Каковы
мои ограничения и каковы мои
возможности третий Каково моё место в
этой игре или в этом мире кто я Я игрок
или шахматная
фигура если я шахматная фигура то кто Я
король слон или
пешка ведь наша жизнь и есть та самая
шахматная доска на которой
разворачивается вся эта игра только
после того как Вы ответите на эти
вопросы вы сможете эффективно применять
инструменты
суперпозиции о том какие инструменты
суперпозиции
поговорим в следующих видео А сейчас
продолжим суперпозиция - это не про
способность ловить везение это про
способность формировать закономерное
везение Я бы даже выразился немного
по-другому суперпозиция - это
целенаправленная деятельность по
созданию закономерного везения И
максимальному его использованию Прим
имения в какой сре
Дея хотите достигать очень крутых
реально крутых результатов то вам не
обойтись без чёткого понимания того что
такое суперпозиция Каковы её инструменты
и как её эффективно
выстраивать как выстраивать супер
позицию Я Обучаю на своей премиальной
программе амы акме в переводе с
древнегреческого означает точку
наивысшего расцвета потенциала человека
я убеждён что благодаря пол раскрытию
своего потенциала человек сможет
выстроить суперпозиции в результате
которой он сможет достичь закономерного
везения И максимально его использовать в
следующем видео Я раскрою вам тему
везения Какие виды везения бывают и где
они происходят а также я раскрою вам
тему закономерного везения А я на этом с
вами прощаюсь Желаю вам удачи и всего
[музыка]
наилучшего H